ladies and gentlemen of NASA this is  Charles Xavier help is on the way  we're doing space missions now cool we  get the astronauts we bring them home go  heat signatures rising fast we gotta get  out of here where's gene where is she  she should be done did you hear what the  kids are calling you  Phoenix  hello Jean  are you the better question is who are  you  something's happening to me would have  this control bad things happen well it  feels good that power destroyed  everything that ever came into contact  with until you the x-men fear you then  what they fear we seek to destroy  shockula's ooh  a girl dies  she's still off that she's not Jean  anymore  that's right  [Music]